so I've spent the last few days
rotting in this spot right here
and by rotting I mean catching up on admin
and blowing my nose while mentally
I'm deep in a court of wings and ruins
and it turns out if you're sick
you're not cleaning and if you're not cleaning
no one else will
and by my standard
this house is fkd like yes
it's not bio hazard
aside from a few questionable tissues
but I can say I'm confident those tissues origins for a change
I've dedicated an hour to sorting out my shithole
which is not a sentence that should be taken literally
and spoiler alert one hour turns to two and then two and a half
and halfway through I do have a minor mental breakdown
but prior to that the clean started well
I was in good spirits I had Chappell Roan blasting on the headphones
I lit me a few fk off candles to tell everyone
you know to fk off
and then I came across my husband's laundry system
which I won't lie deeply triggered me
and it was right about this time that the man in question walked in
with three kids and tie from the park
and I don't know about you
but I really don't like cleaning with people in the house
mainly cause it's about as pointless as
playing hide and seek with yourself
and family games night is always such a core memory
I just love breaking up arguments
Bending the rules and packing it up all by myself
So for today's clean I’ve
decided to go room by room and technically
this is just one big room
it's a split level dual lounge in our very mid century home
and obviously it's our living area
so we spend the majority of the time that we live in here
and don't get me wrong I love living
but I would like to speak to someone about the sheer amount of
admin created just from being alive
and on that note
I won't be cleaning my kitchen for you today
because that room is currently under renovation
and it would have been done sooner
if I didn't have to spend 90% of my time
recleaning the same things over and
over but it's fine
and honestly I might not have seen this sink
in a worse state than this and please
someone tell me how they got toothpaste on the wall
and if I thought the sink was bad
the toilet was so much worse
and I'm gonna save you that trauma by just doing transition
the depressing thing about this clean is it looks like I'm doing a lot of stuff
but I've barely moved the needle
and I'm almost embarrassed to show you my bedroom
but fk it I've been rotting in this room too
so I cleaned literally everything and changed the sheets
but didn't have the energy to film so a transition will have to do
now this is always my favourite part of any clean
mainly because it's so fleeting
and this part is just a big old hint to my husband
to buy me some flowers for the table
once everything was clean
it was time for me to get stuck into my book
just kidding I've got 3 kids to deal with
so I can't read till later